مع مرور مئه يوم على احتجاجات ايران دعوات
لتظاهر بكثافه اليوم والسلطات ترفع سلاح
الاعدامات في وجه المحتاجين
واشنط تدعوا بوتر لسحب الجيش من اوكرانيا
والرئيس الروسي يطالب شركات الدفاع في
بلاده بزياده انتاج الاسلحه
وتضامن مع الجاليه الكرديه
[موسيقى]
اسعد الله صباحكم بكل خير واهلا بكم
الانبار من العربيه تدخل تظاهرات في ايران
يومها المئه لم تضعف حدتها ولم تتراجع
وتيره التصعيد لدى المحتاجين الاحتجاجات
التي تحدث المرشده الايراني
احتجاجات في الايام المقبله يتقدمهم
والفنانين والادباء والبارزون من ابناء
المجتمع وكافه اطياف ابناء الشعب الايراني
اعلن تقرير للمجلس التنسيقي لنقابات
المعلمين الايرانيين ان النظام حكم على
محاسبه مدر او مدرسه غير ربحيه في ايران
او مدرسه تدعى يرى اقاربي بسجن اثني عشر
عاما بتهمتي تشجيع الفساد والتجمع
والتواطؤ ضد الامن القومي
القاء القبض على اقابي جاء وفقا لتقرير
المزيف من والدتي احداث الميراث المدرسه
هذا وقالت منظمه حقوق الانسان الايرانيه
ان النظام اعتقل 39 صحفيه على الاقل في
الفتره ما بين منتصف سبتمبر و30 من نوفمبر
الماضيه واضافه المنظمه انه منذ مقتل
الفتاه الكرديه ماسه بيني اتسع دائره
تضييق الحكوميه في ايران لتشمل حتى
الصحفيين العاملين في وسائل الاعلام
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
كلها تعيش بالمتظاهرين اما هوائها
تدمع العيون اطلقتها قوه الامن لتفريق
صفوفهم واخماد حناجرهم التي من فكت تصبح
بالمراه والحياه والحريه منذ مقتل الشاب
مساء امي
وذهابا الى ساحه اصفهان فان رائحه موت تعم
المدينه التاريخيه لا سيما في ميدان
الشهيد علي خان الذي قد يصبح من ضده اعدام
لعشره المحتاجين يقولوا شهود عيان لشبكه
سي ان ان الامريكيه ان تركيبا منصته هناك
بدا بالفعل وقد يكون امير مصر ازداني
اللاعب الايراني السابق في فريق تراكتور
لكره القدم اول من يلقى حذفه بعد ان اتهمه
النظام بالمشاركه مع مجموعه مسلحه يزعم
انها قتلت العديد من عناصر الامن ففي هذه
الساحه و ديسمبر
قد تنتهي كل الاحلام شهر النهايات ربما
يراه النظام الايراني فرصه لتنفيذ موجه
اعدامات حيث اكدت سي ان ان بان القضاء
يسرع في اصدار الاحكام وتطبيقها ووفق
بيانات الشبكه فان 43 شخصا على الاقل
سيواجهون اعداما وشيكا بينهم معاشره اشخاص
في اصفهان والعدد يصل الى الضعف بحسب
ترجيحه وسائل اعلام ايرانيه
عائلات المعتقلين مذعوره ابنائها خلف
القضبان والعالم يستعد لاستقبال عام جديد
ومخاوف من انشغال بالاحتفالات ونسيان ما
يجري على ارضهم ورغم ذلك صامدونهم
الايرانيون حتى لو كان هذا العام شهد اكثر
الايام فتا فيما عرف في زاهدان بسم الجمعه
الداميه اسراء الصغير العربيه
عضله الحكومه الالمانيه انها شرعت رسميا
في تعليق ائتمان تصدير وضبانات الاستثمار
للاعمال التجاريه في ايران
الايرانيه للاحتجاجات وقالت وزاره
الاقتصاد الالمانيه انها علقت ايضا الصيغه
الاقتصاديه الاخرى بما فيها حوار حول
قضايا الطاقه في ضوء الوضع الذي وصفته
بالخطير للغايه في ايران
الولايات المتحده الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين الى الاعتراف بالواقع وسحب جيشه من
اوكرانيا بعد وصفه النزاع هناك بانه حرب
قال متحدث باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه انه
منذ الرابع والعشرين من فبراير ادركته
الولايات المتحده وبقيه العالم ان العمليه
العسكريه الخاصه لبتون كانت حربا عدوانيه
وغير مبرره ضد اوكرانيا واخيرا وبعد 300
يوم من المعارك وصفتنا الحرب كما هي
النظافه المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه
على انهاء هذه الحرب من خلال سحب قوته من
اوكرانيا
طلب الرئيس الرصيف الى جميل شركات لتصنيع
الاسلحه في بلاده بدله قصاره جهدهم لضمان
حصول الجيش الروسي على جميع الاسلحه
والمعدات العسكريه التي يحتاجها للقتال في
اوكرانيا وقال بوتين خلال زياره لمركز
تونه لتصنيع الاسلحه ان العمليه العسكريه
في اوكرانيا تاتي في اطار جهد تاريخي
لمواجهه ما اسماؤه التاثير الزائد على
الحد للقوى الغربيه على الشئون العالميه
وبعد ايام على زياره الرئيس الوكراني الى
واشنطن وافق الكونجرس على حزمه مساعدات
الاوكرانيا بنحو 45 مليار دولار الدعم
الامريكيه الاوكرانيا ياتي ضمن ميزانيه
فيدراليه بلغت قيمتها ترليونان وسبعه 100
مليار دولار
هذا هو شكلت رحله الرئيس الامريكي
بالنسبه لكثيرين خاصه في ظل حاله الحرب
التي تعرفها اوكرانيا واشتداد القتال مع
القوات الروسيه لهذا التقرير نتعرف على
مشاري رحله
مثل ما يحدث عاده في افلام الجاسوسيه او
العامل السري الاشهر 007 او مهمه مستحيله
زيليسكي يسافر الى واشنطن ويعود الى كياف
اجراءات غير عاديه تم اتخاذها لنقل الرئيس
الاوكراني الى العاصمه الامريكيه فتهديد
الصواريخ الروسيه تجعل السفر الجويه فوق
اوكرانيا محفوفا بالمخاطر الرحله انطلقت
ليلا عبر القطار الى بولندا صور من
التلفزيون البولندي اظهرت قطار اوكرانيا
باللونين الازرق والاصفر وبمحاذاته عدد من
المرافقين يسيرون على طول الرصيف بصحبه
زنسكي الذي ارتدى خلافا للبروتوكولات ستره
عسكريه خضراء وسروال عسكريه ثم دخلت
المجموعه في قافله من السيارات المنتظره
قبل ركوب طائره تابعه للقوه الجويه
اقلعت من مطار الجيش على بعد حوالي ثمانين
كيلومترا الى الغرب وقبل ان تدخل الطائره
المجال الجويه فوق الشمال قامت الطائره
تجسس تابعه لحلف شمال الاطلسي بمسح
المنطقه اذ من المعروف ان الغواصه الروسيه
تحرص البحر قبل ان ترافق رحله زينسكي في
جزء منها طائره مقاتله امريكيه من طراز اف
15 اقلعت من قاعده في انجلترا طائره
زينسكي تجهت الى الشمال الغربي نحو
المملكه المتحده ومن هناك اكمل طريقها الى
الولايات المتحده وبعد حوالي عشر ساعات من
الاقلاع هبطت الطائره بالقرب من واشنطن
عند وصوله حصل زنسكي على حمايه الخدمه
السريه كما هو الحال مع جميع رؤساء الدول
الزائرين لكن مسؤوليه الامن كانوا اكثر
يقظه وبعد ان مرت زياره بثلاثه وبحلول
الخميس قد عاد بالفعل الى الاراضي
الاوروبيه ونشر عبر التليجرام انه توقف في
بولندا للقاء نظيره دوده ليكمل مغامره الى
كاف من جديد
بلال الوجديني العربي
الجزء الذي يسيطر عليه الجيش الاوكراني من
منطقه زاباروجا مصادر مطلعه افادت بسماع
دوين في جارات في المدينه التي قضت ليله
من حاله التاهب والاستغفار تحسبا لهجوم
جوي مرتب كما دوت صفارته في عدد من المدن
الاوكرانيه تحسبا بهجمات روسيه
اعرب وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه عن عمي
تعاطفه مع الشعبين الكردي والفرنسي بعد
انقتل مصلح ثلاثه اشخاص في مركز ثقافي
وصالون لتصفيف الشعر في باريس
في تغريده على تويتر كله تعاطف مع ضحايا
الهجوم على المركز الثقافي الكردي في
باريس
الكرديه والشعب فرنسا في هذا اليوم الذي
وصفه بالحزن
كمادات حكومه اقليم كردستان العراق الهجوم
على الاكراد في فرنسا وضعتهم للالتزام
بالهدوء
الحكومه في بيانها ان لديها ثقه كامله في
مؤسسات الحكومه الفرنسيه والنظام القضائي
في البلاد
لاتخاد الاجراءات اللازمه لحمايه الاقراض
المقيمين في فرنسا ومحاسبه منافذ الهجوم
يوم فارسي طويل ومطرب اعتداء على مركز
كردي في العاصمه اود بحياه ثلاثه اشخاص
الاذانات الشديده لما وقع من السلطات
الفرنسيه لم تتاخر لكنها لم تاخر ما كانت
تخشاه الحشود الكرديه الغاضبه بدات تتجمع
تمهيدا لتظاهرات تحولت الاحتجاجات
وزير الداخليه زار المكان وحاول السباق
الاحداث جلال دار معنا قال انه امر كافه
اجهزه الشرطه بحمايه مناطق تواجد الجاليه
الكرديه
امرت اجهزه الشرطه في باريس وفي اماكن
اخرى من التراب الوطني بحمايه الاماكن
التي تتجمع فيها الجاليه الكرديه
كلام وزير الداخليه لم يكن كافيا لتفادي
اعمال شغب ومواجهه واشتباكات مع الشرطه
الفرنسيه التي عززت حضورها لا سيما في
منطقه ستراسبورغسان دوني حرق للحاويات
وتكسير
[تصفيق]
الشرطه استعملت القناه الى المسيله للدموع
لتفريغ المتظاهرين الرئيس الفرنسي
ايمانويل
حادث اطلاق النار وصفا اياه بالهجوم
المشين الذي استهدف اكراد فرنسا
غير ان المواجهات لم تتوقف الصوره تلخص ما
حدث وتنذر بما قد يحدث
تتابعون ايضا في هذه النشره ولكن بعد قليل
منصه تويتر تزيله خاصيه البحث عن مساعده
في مجالات المختلفه مختلفه بين الصحه
العقليه واستغلال الاطفال
اهلا بكم من جديد افاد المرصد السوري
لحقوق الانسان ان تركيا تستعد لارسال
الدفعه جديده من المقاتلين السوريين الى
ليبيا واضاف البصمه
مع رحيل عشرات المقاتلين السوريين الذين
كانوا يعملون ضمن الفصائل الموالي لتركيا
على ليبيا متجهين الى انقره
عبدالله اليوم القادسيه في البلاد على
تجنب اي تصعيد من شانه تهديد وحده
واستقرار ليبيا الذي وصفه بالهاش
السياسيين في ليبيا ان يكون قوه دافعه لحل
الازمه الليبيه التي طالبها من خلال
التوافق على حل مبني على توافق وطني
من جانبه قال رئيس حكومه الوحده الوطنيه
الليبيه عبد الحميد دبي في لقاء مع
العربيه ان الانتخابات لن تجرى قبل اقرار
القاعده الدستوريه في البلاد
لا يمكن ان تكون باي شكل من الاشكال
مستقره الا من خلال قاعده دستوريه او
دستور
اذا كانوا ديوان مجلس النواب ومجلس الدوله
والله اي شخص يقر بانه يدخل في قاعده
دستوريه من بكره نحن نسلم
الانتخابات نعم متى تحدث الانتخابات عندما
يتم اقرار القاعده الدستوريه
الرئيس التونسيه الرئيس سعيد خلال لقاء مع
وزيره العوده ليلى جفال وفقا لمعلمته
رئاسه التونسيه على ان القضاء العادل
ضروريه لتطهير البلاد من الذين عبثوا
بمقدراتها واجرموا في حقها على حد قوله
وتناول اللقاء ايضا مساله زمن التقاضي حيث
اشار الرئيس الجمهوريه الى انه من غير
مقبول ان تظل قضايا قائمه لمده سنوات دون
وقع مركز الملك سلمان الاغاثه والاعمال
الانسانيه اتفاقيه جديده مع برنامج
الاغذيه العالميه تهدف لتلبيه الاحتياجات
الغذائيه الاساسيه للفئات الاكثر احتياجا
في اليمن بقيمه 20 مليون دولار مركز الملك
سلمان او ضحانا الاتفاقيه سيستفيدوا منها
اكثر من نصف مليون شخص
في واشنطن اوسط تقرير نهائي لجنه
التحقيقات في احداث من يناير في مجلس
النواب الامريكيه بيحضر الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب من الترشحي مره اخرى وكانت
اللجنه وصلت ايضا بتوجيهي تهم التحريض على
تمرد والمساعده عليه
والتامل ضد الولايات المتحده والتامر
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
حقبه جديده من المواجهه بين الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب وخصومه
والقضاء تبدا مع نشر تقرير النهائي للجنه
التحقيق في مجلس النواب بشان احداث السادس
من يناير
يوصي بان ينظر الكونجرس في منع ترامب من
توليه منصبا عاما مره اخرى لدوره التحريضي
على التمرد يومها مؤكدا خياطه بشكل اجرامي
نتائج الانتخابات وفشله في التصرف لمنع
مؤيده من مهاجمه
من قبل الحزب الجمهوري حيث من المحتمل ان
يقول الكثير من الجمهوريين انهم يحبون
ترامب لكن لديه الكثير من المشاكل وهو غير
مرشح لا يفوز مثل مرشحين اخرين
لكن ورغم ان توصيات اللجنه غير ملزمه
لوزاره العدل التي تقررون نيابتها العامه
البث في توجيه التهامه ينظر العديد اليها
على انها خارطه طريق للعداله لكن من دون
جدول زمني واضح
في منصبه ولا يملك اي من مزايا كونه رئيسا
للولايات المتحده ويخضع الى حد كبير لنطاق
كونه قيد التحقيق وربما يواجه اتهاما
جنائيا من قبل وزاره العدل
وكان جمهوريون في مجلس الشيوخ اعلن هو بعد
توصيات اللجنه بتوجيه التهم الى ترامب
انهم لا يحمونه خاصه حلفاء زعيمهم في
المجلس الذي قال ان الامه باكملها تعرف من
المسؤول عن الهجوم في اشاره الى ترامب
الذي اتهم اللجنه بالسعي لمنعه من الترشح
للانتخابات الرئاسيه المقبله
الاولى التي يح وفيها نظام العداله
الجنائيه الامريكيه مرشحا رئاسيا ورئيسا
سابقا لهذا يرى خبراء ان ذلك عبئا على
الوزاره لكي تقوم بهذه السابقه ما قد
يجعلها تتردد قبل اتخاذ القرار حسين
الطاوض العربيه
وايدانات دوليه لقرار طالبان منع الفتيات
من التعليم فيما تواصل طالبان في تقديم
مبرراته مراسلنا عبد الله نادر التقى احدى
الطالبات المتضرره يعني هذا القرار
صعب للغايه ان تجلس وحيدا بعد سنين طوال
من الدراسه والتعليم المتواصل في مثل هذه
الغرفه مع كتب وكراسات تذكر بالماضي
المفقود كما تقول مارينا الطالبه الجامعيه
التي منعتها طالبان في مرسومها الجديد
بمنع الاناث من التعليم
الفتيات كنت ادرس للامتحان النهائي غدا
اغلقت الكتاب وخابت جميع اعمالي يظهر وزير
التعليم العالي الرجل الاول في ملف منع
الفتيات من الدراسه على شاشه التلفزيون
ليقدم التبريرات قديمه جديده في مقدمه
استمرار الاختلاط بين الطالبات والطلاب
والمساس بين الجنسين لم يكن حسب التوجيهات
المقدمه الى الدارسين والدارسات
طقس في معظم الجامعات لم تنتهي عمليه
الاختلاط بين الذكور والاناث بعد وهذه
قضيه لا تجيذها الشريعه البته
لقرار طالبان بحرمان الفتيات من التعليم
فقد استقال من جامعات مختلفه حكوميه
واهليه ما يقارب من 50 من الاساتذه
الجامعيين في وقت يضرب عدد من الطلاب في
جامعات عده عن الحضور للدراسه فيها
طالبا تبرر قرارها والطالبات يرفضنا
ويطالبنا بازاله العقبات الامنيه
والاقتصاديه والتعليميه لا ان يتم القضاء
على تعليمهن كما يجب تقليم الاظافر اذا
طالت وليس قطع الاصابع بحسب تعبيرهم عبد
لنادر العربيه كابول
وزاره المنصه توتير احد ميزاتها التي كانت
تظهر وسائل الاتصال المباشره لمنع
الانتحار للمستخدمين الذين يبحثون عن
محتوى معين
لتعليمات الى الماسك حسب ما فاد شخصين
مطلعان وكانت تظهر للمستخدمين خاصيته توجد
مساعده في الجزء العلوي لعمليه البحث التي
تربط المستخدمه بمنظمات في مجالات مختلفه
مثل الصفحه العقليه والايت واللقاحات
والاستغلال الجنسي للاطفال والعنف وحريه
التعبير
ربما يؤدي الى زياده المخاوف بشان
المستخدمين الضعفاء وفيما يقوله
المحتوى الضار تنخفضه
في اكتوبر
تراجعات الحقوقيه ان المحتوى الذي يضم
اهانات عنصريه والحظ على الكراهيه
شهيده العاصمه العراقيه بغداد تساقط امطار
عزيزه تسببت في غرق الكثير من الشوارع
الى وسط البلد
[موسيقى]
من مخاطر عاصفه ثلجيه تحمل معها موجه
ساقعه قطبي وتم وطرقات الرئيسيه والغاء
رحلات جويه عاديه
[موسيقى]
قتل 20 شخص في حريق دلع بالمنزل للمصلين
في مدينه كيماروفو والسيبيريه
السلامه من الحرائق مطابق الثاني احترق
بالكامل قبل ان تتم السيطره على الحريق
يذكر وانا العديد من دور المسنين
في جميع انحاء روسيا ولا يمكن ان تخضع
لعمليات التفتيش لانها تعتبر ملكيه خاصه
الختام تذكيره في العالم
بالتزامني مع مرور 100 يوم على احتجاجات
ايران دعوات لتظاهر بكثافه اليوم وسلطات
ترفع سلاح الاعدامات في وجه المحتجين
واشنطن الى سحب الجيش
الدفاع بزياده انتاج الاسلحه
الفرنسي
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]